i shall tell you a few words about the
beginning of injustice
the cultural destruction of the occupied
area of cyprus
we estimate fifteen thousand to twenty
thousand icons have been removed
several dozen major frescoes and mosaics
have been segmented for sale abroad
and some destroyed forever i heard
about this young lady
here in holland from cyprus who had a
big heart for her country
the dutch art dealer approached me
with a proposition to deliver many of
our important stolen treasures
if it wasn't for her
the operation wouldn't have taken place
in munich
the dutch art dealer directly implicated
the possessor
which culminated in the arrest of the
possessor
and discovery of many more artifacts of
cypriot origin
so she took a certain risk but it
resulted
in
a lot of pieces going back to cyprus
s is cypriot a refugee from farm augusta
and speaking for the people of cyprus we
have lost many many things since 1974
however
there can be no greater loss
than that one's culture
um
thank you
to help you understand my narrative
today please allow me to share with you
a few snapshots from my life
imagine me as a 14 year old school girl
at my hometown in famagusta where
shakespeare staged othello
we lived just a block away from the
mediterranean sea
i was lucky enough to have spent my
early years in a loved family full of
rituals and tradition
we began and finished our day with
prayers
using the icons to communicate with the
divine
saint andrew
was a favorite scent for my mom and we
prayed daily to
him this was my childhood the mosaic of
my harmonious life
in 1974 i went to bed as a free teenager
and woke up in the midst of war and
horror
war devastated me shattered my dreams
and all i gained was a new identity one
of a refugee
just like millions of other refugees
around the world
we had no choice but to start making new
lives elsewhere in my case life took me
to the uk and then to the netherlands
where i started an i.t business in my
twenties
in 1987 the cypriot authorities who
heard of my successes appointed me as
honorary console in holland
a strange phone call changed my life
it was from the mysterious dutch art
dealer you saw on the video michelle for
ryan
in the oldest cafe in the hague he
showed me some images which profoundly
shocked me
picture of mosaics or scented dress
he showed me these pictures of the
mosaic of santa andrew 6th century and
unique worldwide
millions of small stones collected from
all around the island assembled together
to create the images of christ and his
apostles
saint andrew was on sale
his neigh face and all other apostles
hacked out of a wall with brute force by
those who wanted to make profit for what
for us the people of cyprus are
priceless
i soon realized what i was seeing
mosaics from the cana career church from
the 6th century in other words art from
the dawn of christian history some of
the oldest religious images in the world
up to that point i lived as the silent
witness of the war seeing those mosaics
made me thirsty for justice and my
personal mission as a campaigner against
the looting and trafficking was born
my passion has led me to many different
places around the globe
from police stations in germany to
universities in japan and to parliaments
of several countries including this one
i have received help and encouragement
from museum curators art historians
collectors possessors i worked with
interpol clerics controversial dealers
but at the end more than 200 works of
stolen religious art traveled back home
to cyprus
a drop in the ocean compared to the
thousands of arts still missing
the emotional value of these artifacts
are beyond measure
in 1997
i worked with interpol and the german
police and we staged the sting operation
in munich with the help of orion
five thousand artifacts were found by
the police in eidon digman's apartment
in munich hidden behind double walls in
double ceilings
saint andrew was discovered but he was a
fake
the real one is still missing
for 30 years aidan dickman says that for
ryan controls the mosaic
wherefore ryan claims that digman
controls it
there they are
we have a picture of diekmann holding
the mosaic and his former partner for
ryan holding the lower part of the
figure of christ which is also still
missing yet the dealers remain free and
neither of these mosaics are featured on
any police list as missing
i know how a refugee or immigrant from
afghanistan iraq syria or mali feels
seen wealthy europeans buying symbols of
their homes identity history memories
and faith
this is why now i want to share my
network and resources to help others
protect their cultural heritage but
don't know how
if the system for monitoring looted art
was working well with optimal
cooperation between police lawyers
museums and ordinary people
then we would have found saint andreas
by now and brought him home
this is
my dream
give every looted art a face and a soul
a voice to tell their truth with their
silence
let us create
together a network
of cultural crime watchers worldwide
because that is the only way to fight
united against the culture in christ
we know that such a mechanism of
collecting anonymous tips from the
public is needed right now as iraqi
immigrants reached out to us for help
we must help them to prevent their
cultural heritage from being sold to
wealthy individuals worldwide like the
cypriot arts where
they need guarantees if they collaborate
with us that their artifacts will go
back to iraq after the conflict and not
stay in our museums
in war zones acts of cultural
desecration can entrench bitterness and
hatred that is often their purpose
however acts of restitution or respect
for cultural heritage can be important
in rebuilding trust peace and
reconciliation
giving back stolen treasures to us
refugees is an acknowledgement for our
losses and a symbol of hope that will
resonate deep in our souls
join us at walk of truth our ngo so
together we can convert the silent
witnesses of war and destruction into
envoys of peace we cannot do this alone
as the task is much bigger than all of
us together
as we see daily in the news
thank you very much and thank the
organizers for this opportunity